dix huit cas d'infection à la bactérie
e.coli liés à la ligue sur eux mais
n'ont été rapportés à ce jour au québec
et en ontario 3 en ontario 15 au québec
doit-on s'inquiéter sylvain charlebois
professeur en distribution et politiques
agroalimentaires anniversaire dalhousie
halifax charlebois bonsoir robot fait
deux fois là au moins deux fois que ça
arrive avec la romaine pourquoi ça
c'était il ya un an à peu près pourquoi
ça arrive et ça touche la romaine
c'est c'est un peu inusité 1 face à dieu
depuis certains moments depuis
pratiquement un à l'époque on avait
décidé de retirer des lectures humaines
chez sobeys iga on avait envoyé d'allah
comme on l'a fait hier
avec l' agence publique mais là cette
fois-ci là on en voit d'ailleurs et on
avertit les gens de ne pas manger être
humain autrement dit là l'argent ce
public envoie un vote de non confiance
envers l'arizona et humo forme parce que
ça fait ça fait tellement longtemps que
ça dure on n'a pas déterminé le problème
de façon précise alors il ya des doutes
qui persistent l'actuel mais je m'en
vais vous parler de l'arizona
est-ce qu'on a identifié le lieu où elle
a été cultivé cette laitue le lieu
problématique là bas non disent pas
ouvertement mais sauf ça ressemble un
peu à ce que l'on ressent quand on l'a
vu en californie quelques années avec le
code des épinards josune lost un peu la
même chose on a des pâturages du bétail
pas très loin
une rivière et lâchant deux cultivent à
sion 2 où on cultive la lettre sur
romaine alors tout ça en fait
forment une combinaison qui peut qui
peut vraiment représenter des risques
substantiels pour des consommateurs donc
c'est pas de l'école de romaine mais là
c'est plus le temps vous allez me dire
mais des codes de laitue romaine du
québec par exemple cultivés ici on a
fait beaucoup la dalle à la région de
montréal ce n'est pas des décors de
romaine dit si on ne croit pas là c'est
vraiment de la romaine importer pendant
donc la fin de l'automne ouais vous
savez monsieur roy le problème c'est que
le consommateur qui va aller visiter son
épicerie jusque là personnes entassées
les tue donc c'est la laitue américaine
s'est prévalue canadienne c'est
l'iceberg la baston qui va écoper à
raison de ce qui se passe actuellement
le plus plusieurs jours aux etats-unis
c'est aussi même avis uj états unis donc
ça commence à prendre de grosses
proportions quand même faut absolument
passer il ya eu un corps dans les
maritimes qui a été déclaré quelques
instants le don que ça m'aurait surpris
si l' alerte aurait affecté que deux
provinces
moi je n'ai presque aura d'autres cas
ailleurs donc on parle d'un problème
continental et c'est la réalité
d'aujourd'hui
la production est tellement intense que
lorsqu'un éclosion
c'est une éclosion qui affecte
l'ensemble du territoire nord américain
ok mais on fait croire conclusion on
attend que ça passe
on attend qu'on trouve la source puis la
rivière un soulier par les excréments de
ben quoi ben je mens tas de choses
georges matin une foule de jackson sur
scène qu'ils soient qui devient plus
sévère envers l'industrie on en attend
autant que l'industrie avec ses propres
solutions on peut plus attendre c'est
une chose la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
va falloir changer les politiques liées
au territoire à la gestion du territoire
agricole en arizona
il va falloir apprendre de ce qui s'est
passé en quelques jours ni le bétail et
lettres romaines à côté de l'autre ça va
pas très bien où acheter de la laitue
d'ici qui pousse à auxerre les et les
étiquettes on est en novembre
salut merci monsieur change au revoir
bientôt